bonjour à tous apple est attaqué en
justice pour obsolescence programmée
pour avoir ralenti délibérément ses
anciens iphone dans cette vidéo on va
s'intéresser au fait on va regarder ce
qui s'est réellement passé
qu'est-ce que l'obsolescence programmée
et au final est ce que apple a vraiment
utilisé l'obsolescence programmée et si
oui est-ce qu'on peut encore leur faire
confiance et ça on va le regarder
[Musique]
c'est un peu le bordel il ya déception
pour tous les utilisateurs d'apple
puisque depuis le mois de décembre 2010
est apple et a été attaqué en justice
pour obsolescence programmée alors on va
faire un petit retour sur l'historique
pour voir un peu réellement ce qui s'est
passé et comme d'habitude j'ai bien
travaillé
alors tout a commencé le 18 décembre
2017 avec un article publié sur le blog
dit belge qui a fait vraiment un
comparatif entre les performances des
iphone d'ancienne génération enfin pas
tant celle que ça s 6 7 pour voir les
performances des modèles neufs par
rapport aux modèles anciens et ils vont
effectivement relevé une vraie
différence de performance à la suite de
quoi deux jours après apple a répondu en
confirmant le fait qui est [ __ ]
délibérément leurs processeurs leur
iphone pour contrecarrer la perte de
puissance des batteries au lithium ion
qui vieillissent moins bien et pour
éviter d'endommager le matériel
ils disent non qu'ils ont voulu protéger
les batteries en lissant les pics de
performance donc ralentir le smartphone
afin d'éviter les bugs
la firme aurait aussi intégrer cette
fonction était sur ses iphone 7
s'activerait uniquement lorsque la
batterie deviendrait trop vieille à la
suite de quoi lieu plusieurs plaintes
qui ont été déposées aux états unis en
israël
et maintenant en france pour faire la
lumière sur tout ça et pour voir si
apple a vraiment triché et a vraiment
fait appel à l'obsolescence programmée
la première plainte elle a été déposée
par deux étudiants en droit de
l'université de los angeles
stéphane bogdanovic et dakota spears qui
reproche à apple de ne pas avoir demandé
la permission aux utilisateurs avant
d'imposer la nouvelle fonctionnalité il
leur reproche également d'avoir
interféré volontairement pour endommager
les iphone et pousser les consommateurs
et remplacés par des modèles plus
puissants
il ya une deuxième plainte qui a été
déposée aux états unis par cinq citoyens
représentants de l'illinois qui
représentait l'illinois l'indiana l'ohio
et la caroline du nord alors l'objectif
est de transformer cette plainte en
class action au nom des quatre états
américains
ce qui fait qu'ils auraient vraiment une
plainte de groupe avec beaucoup plus de
monde derrière et forcément beaucoup
plus de poids est beaucoup plus de
répercussions
cette deuxième plainte n'attaque pas
directement apple par rapport aux filles
de ralentir les iphone mais plutôt de ne
pas avoir expliqué aux consommateurs
pendant un an et jusqu'à ce que les
consommateurs sur la perçoivent eux
mêmes
effectivement il a vécu
à cette pratique selon eux apple aurait
dû leur donner le choix soit le client
aurait accepté le ralentissement de la
vieille machine et ce sera adapté soit
il aurait changé sa batterie faut savoir
quelqu'un remplacement de batterie aux
etats unis ses 79 dollars ou alors deux
ont aussi préféré que le client puisse
choisir tout seul en connaissance de
cause de remplacer son matériel les
plaignants veulent donc prouver qu'ils
ont acheté un modèle plus récent
à cause de ce problème de performance
alors qu'il aurait tout simplement pu
acheter une batterie ou du moins en
faire le choix éclairés ou qu'ils
attaquent plutôt apple sur son manque de
transparence plutôt que sur sa vraie
volonté de pousser le consommateur à
acheter un nouvel iphone apple réponses
sont bonnes raisons techniques validées
par nombreux experts de ralentir les
performances des anciens iphone pour
effectivement protéger le matériel et
prolonger la durée de vie donc ils vont
vraiment à l' inverse de ce que dénonce
une obsolescence programmée alors
justement on va se poser la question
qu'est ce que l'obsolescence programmée
pour vous le dire très simplement
j'avais textuelle ou le lire c'est
l'ensemble des techniques par lesquels
un metteur en marché vise notamment par
la conception du produit à raccourcir
délibérément la durée de vie ou
d'utilisation potentiel de ce produit
afin d'en augmenter le taux de son
remplacement
et c'est justement là dessus qu'apple
dit le contraire et disques justement
l'idée c'était pas de remplacer ses
iphone mais de prolonger leur durée de
vie les aurait donc [ __ ] les iphone
délibérément pour prolonger la vie et
éviter justement que les consommateurs
les changes
et c'est justement ce pour l'acs est
compliquée et qui va rendre la tâche
difficile aux juges
est ce qu'apple a vraiment fait de
l'obsolescence programmée en bridant ses
appareils ou alors est-ce qu'apple bien
au contraire souhaite prolonger la durée
vie des appareils même s'il ya des class
action aux états unis même si à des
plaintes en france en israël est
probablement très bientôt dans le reste
du monde ça va être très très très
compliqué à prouver malgré tout je sais
pas pourquoi j'ai le sentiment qu'il ya
quand même une petite notion
d'obsolescence programmée derrière tout
ça et je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
sous l'oeil sur le site d'apple vont
regarder toutes les informations
concernant le remplacement des écrans le
remplacement des batteries
il est très clairement noté qu'une
batterie coupe 89 euros en france a
remplacé dont apple aurait très bien pu
faire une note pour informer ses clients
qu'il était complètement
il de changer sa batterie et c'est en ça
qu'il ya un vrai problème parce qu'apple
n'a pas joué la transparence
il est évident que pour eux il est plus
intéressant que des clients à changer
leur iphone régulièrement donc changer
les batteries donc malgré tout ça le
doute est là et ça sent quand même
l'absence programmée
le problème c'est aussi qu à peu la
tenue d'être mis au pied du mur ils
auraient pu donner l'information dès
2016 ce qu'ils ont fait le choix de
brider le matériel en disant voilà on
vous propose cette option vous pouvez
l'activer dans cette nouvelle mise à
jour d'ios
vous pouvez faire le choix de changer
votre batterie ou alors carrément de
renouveler votre matériel et ça apple
cancun n'a pas du tout est transparent
qu'est ce que dit la loi en france la
loi sur la transition énergétique a créé
le délit d'obsolescence programmée qui
punit d'une peine maximale de deux ans
de prison allant jusqu'à trois cents
mille euros d'amendé et 5 % du chiffre
d'affaires annuel et en plus du délit
sur l'obsolescence programmée
l'association qui a porté plainte en
france qui s'appelle association hop
halte à l'obsolescence programmée les
accuse également de tromperie ça a l'air
d'avoir trompé leurs clients en ayant
effectivement ralentissent matériel et
du fait que le client n'ait pas été
informé il faut savoir que la loire non
de 2014 restaure la possibilité pour les
associations de défendre les
consommateurs et de lancer pour eux une
action group l'association hope a donc
déposé plainte en son nom mais il est
complètement possible de faire entendre
sa voix par le biais d'un formulaire et
je vous ai mis d'ailleurs ce lien dans
la description que risque apple dans
tout ça tout d'abord une condamnation il
va être très compliqué de prouver
l'obsolescence programmée puisque
effectivement la ligne de défense
d'apple c'est bien au contraire de
prolonger la durée dit son matériel
mais je dirais que là où apple a
vraiment le plus à perdre c'est la
confiance de ses clients et ça justement
je pense que la confiance elle en a pris
un très grand coup derrière la casquette
ce que vous dites que votre fabricant en
qu'elle vous croyez la marque que vous
aimez sur laquelle vous avez quand même
de l'argent ce qu'elles sont quand même
des produits premium met en place des
mises à jour de leur système pour
réduire les performances de votre
appareil sans que vous en soyez mis au
courant et vous soyez pas du tout
informés alors qu'en simple remplacement
de la batterie aurait suffi à résoudre
le problème apple pour très clairement
dire
nos batteries ne dure que deux ans au
bout de deux ans les appareils
ralentissent les performances sont
beaucoup moins donc pour vous protéger
vous pouvez activer la fonctionnalité
sinon pour à peine 100 euros pourrait
remplacer votre batterie retrouver des
performances idéal si les clients
partent à la concurrence forcément le
chiffre d'affaires va dégringoler et ça
fera la sphère de qui est bien des
concurrents et en premier lieu
samsung samsung qui s'apprête à sortir
deux nouveaux smartphones de frapper
très fort en 2018 il est très clair que
si samsung ne se fait pas épinglé pour
les mêmes pratiques
ils gagneront de la confiance de la
crédibilité et à contrario apple va
perdre alors la question qui se pose
maintenant c'est peut-on encore faire
confiance à apple
ma réponse est très claire oui de toute
façon apple s'est fait épingler donc
maintenant tout le monde le sait ils
vont être obligés de corriger ça ils
vont être obligés de laisser le choix
aux consommateurs soient effectivement
envoie une mise à jour d'ios en
proposant la possibilité d'activer la
réduction de performance pour protéger
le matériel ou alors on va pouvoir
sciemment maintenant qu'on sait
remplacer nos batteries et retrouver les
performances vraiment optimisé en tout
cas normal donc de toute façon apple a
du matériel de très bonne qualité
ça c'est pas nouveau effectivement ils
ont fait une grosse erreur il n'aurait
jamais dû faire ça il ya vraiment à côté
loyal par rapport au client qui n'est
pas là mais ça ne fait pas d'apple pour
autant une marque malhonnête ça ne fait
pas d'apple pour autant une marque qui a
du matériel de mauvaise qualité
donc je pense qu'il faut pas se tromper
de combat il est très clair qu'il faut
pas du tout informé leurs clients alors
qu'ils auraient dû le faire mais
néanmoins ça reste quand même une
excellente marque dites moi ce que vous
en pensez si vous êtes client comme moi
chez apple que vous avez déjà eu
plusieurs produits
est ce que vous êtes déçu je suppose que
oui en tout cas moi je le suis j'ai un
iphone 6 s pour l'instant il rame pas
trop j'ai acheté il ya un an et demi à
peu près pour l'instant les performances
seront encore au rendez vous mais j'ai
bien peur qu elle dégringole très
rapidement donc je vais vraiment rester
vigilant dites moi vous ce que vous en
pensez
mettez moi tout ça en commentaire est-ce
que vous continuez de faire confiance à
apple est-ce que vous continuez à penser
qu'apple propose des bons produits
est ce que pour vous à peu elle est une
bonne marque est-ce qu'on peut encore
lui faire confiance mettez moi tout sans
commentaire je vous invite néanmoins à
l'essai des jolies pousse pas pour apple
mais pour moi on couvre un vrai plaisir
à mettre tous vos commentaires vous
abonner
scène parce que on va parler normes et
mende actualité high tech c'est bien
beau de présenter des produits mais il
faut aussi être là pour parler de la
qualité des marques et même quand on se
fâche abonnez vous je vous dis à bientôt
soyez sages et d'ici là rendez vous bien
[Musique]